a salty honest when I initially saw this
I was like what in the hell when DC came
along in Superman issue number 38 and
gave him a new type of Tower when they
gave him the ability to release all of
the solar energy stored in his cells in
the form of a solar flare I was kind of
like okay I mean this is gonna get some
mixed reviews I mean classic fans of
Superman don't want to see things change
but the current fans of suit ran the new
fans don't mind DC shaking things up a
bit so here's my question if Superman
getting a new power is shaking things up
then what did we call it when DC not
only takes Superman's powers away but
then says he's not Kryptonian anymore
with DC transitioning from convergence
to divergence they recently released a
sneak peek of the upcoming four-part
event called truth which starts the
Superman issue number 41 and deals with
the idea of him and his identity
becoming public but more so than that it
also seems to deal with how he copes
with not having his powers what they
reveal to us here is that when Superman
initially seemed to gain this new Solar
Flare ability that what we knew it took
about 24 hours for his body to recharge
that over this time he's apparently been
losing his powers and what we find is
that we basically pick up with Superman
as he's traveling to the fortress of
solitude
now what Superman tells us here is that
one he can't fly that to the temperature
the extreme temperatures of this
extremely cold region are affecting him
in this sense that he talks about his
muscles aching he talks about how his
fingers are becoming numb all that kind
of good stuff in addition to this he's
actually ambushed by a group of what
appear to be ninjas and he starts
talking about when he's fighting them
back when he's trying to beat them up
about how his knuckles are splitting and
so on and so as far as we can tell
kal-el is human that appears to be the
case here now initially it could just be
that he was in a very weakened state
that was my initial thought here but
this all changes when he arrives to the
fortress of solitude when he gets there
not only does the fortress of solitude
reject his biology as being non
Kryptonian it takes his clothing away it
deals him as though he's a person that
stolen the outfit of Superman as an ends
trying to intrude into the fortress of
solitude and so where Superman is
screaming about how he is Superman
everything states the contrary that he
has no powers he can't fly
he doesn't have super strength his
body's no longer immune to the extreme
cold of the planet Earth he's not
Kryptonian in the eyes of the fortress
of solitude and he doesn't have a
Superman outfit so yeah what in the hell
is going on is what I want to know so
I'm pretty psyched to restore an truth
it's probably the first time in a long
time I'm pretty excited to read Superman
story so that's where we stand right now
and yeah so with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end and I
will catch you guys later peace